[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
professionnellement
c'est en ce moment sachant ce
qu'elle
est si vous avez
la chance
je veux me lancer à 3 face au travail
votre récente à
un collègue et un ami contribuer
par minimum vous avez choisi roubaix
quels sont les scènes monde les trois
personnes on est sportif si je me
demandais de vous décrire en seulement
sept mois
le but de tout cela
est le déterminer
c'est la main de penser à voir
pour vous même et ré et montre que les
autres fois en vous
parce que la réalité et quand vous voyez
les places qui définit comme un saint
en fait
votre perception
2009 avant tout que
[Musique]
quatre ans et que vous deviez pour leurs
aînés en oeuvre pour crédit pour relate
pour créer votre réputation
professionnelle en tant que prévu pour
avoir notre équipe et faire de votre
entreprise à brême parallèlement des
moulins
en fait il s'agit
d'être fidèle à soulaines
tout en maximisant
visibilité
j'ai toujours
évité d'être façon discrète
qui décentralise
réalisation est de même
au début de ma carrière
[Musique]
tu
connais dans le secteur bancaire
il avait aussi
la
chine souffre aux élus le dernier
un beau motif
que ces personnes tôt en
courant
réalisations professionnelles
celle ci ne vous rend elle commenté
à
j pn tu peux trouver on commence là
ce qui ne m'a pas vraiment plu
[Musique]
jusque là j'avais sous tribune et se
montre lui parle de lui même
je pensais que si je travaillais lui la
qualité et à face sereinement
mais ce n'est que lorsque j'ai travaillé
en étroite collaboration avec les
équipes de marketing
et musulmans face et aulas en public on
s'étire sur la croissance des produits
et les mains ce que j'ai réalisé
que mes relations
publiques personnelles aux
réparations de matériel
elle ça parce qu'à partir de ce
moment-là que j'ai n'hésitez pas à lui
mais la réussite professionnelle
a rappelé qu'on ne les y serait qu'un
vol
alors
qu'est ce que le personnel peut
le consommer
c'est là que se différencier et le
contre sens et gland
communication pour projet un message une
image comme le but atteindre un objectif
dédié
pour un décompte en jours le peut son
clavier et une recette personnelle avec
la congélation
rebelles
une personne experts au bout
elles n'ont jamais
développé cette activité
est un outil de communication et de
marketing amélie
pour plus et ce en faisant la paix mais
il joue il faut naître que dans votre
tête que vous voyez là monde
vous deviez vous investir en l'air
et se focaliser sur nous on gesticule
vous feriez communiqué sa pensée dans
votre carrière vous positionnez faisait
brûler
aujourd'hui
vous êtes
ce que vous passez beaucoup se veut
leader cet outil
vous aimez une somme de perception
de réputation d excellence b si dans mon
truc écosystèmes
au
travail et votre travail et votre marque
htc compris et est devancé tous les
services que vous verrez
la première fois des données à jour ce
point cela
est un premier glissement
sur l'île et les mâts et pourquoi
devrions nous essayer pendant
une discussion un nul
entre l'om et vivante
et du monde agir à la source de saint
avold c'est normal les questions
abondent mais où
je réponds
on est on arrive c'est bien ça
elle est douée mais il le frappe alors à
moi j'ai répondu
l'indicé pmi a même c'est ça elle répond
oui et on m'a fait de loin de ça j'ai
dit ok ça avance de recherche de votre
stage
là d'étudiants père et semble pas très
bien
[Musique]
j'ai envoyé les aider j'ai pas eu de
réponse si on porte où
on est en deuxième année on n'a pas
cette expérience les entreprises
cherchent des personnes vivant au moins
trois expériences
[Musique]
il n'a pas découvert assez compliqué
j'ai probablement
en disant allez sur l'aude et ses
cheveux 10 nuls ont reçu le site est de
proposer un stage à rennes les étudiants
qui va donner sur les pieds
ça tu as cru blanc
là toute surprise
les réponses commencent à marcher sur
les pieds il enseigne dans
jeudi il m'a tringles à partager un
contenu intéressant
il attaque les entreprises et les
personnes qui travaillent
[Musique]
et la rétablissement propos des zooms et
ce qu'on fait est fou très à l'aise
dans le marketing digital
l'opus songez avenue et
et qu'il cherchait un sage il a proposé
la joconde et du camp tout
en dînant la chance j'ai bien dit que ce
n'est pas du tout le sens de saint père
a
eu la très ambitieuse
l'un
est toi et moustiques ça te plaît pour
des délits savourer vous éprouvez
bastille où votre stage est de ne pas
faire en sorte
que ce sont les employés qui viennent me
voir pour vous proposer des opportunités
de stages et de mettre deux jours
alors est-ce que ça va ça vous intéresse
et après ces discussions moyennement je
n'ai jamais vu et gestion aussi brillé
aussi intéressé par à coups
le peut ce raid est un moyen des paniers
est un moyen de bien établir
va bien
et par moyenne des séries une image re
et 2 e mais
ils vous aident à le différencier et
nous
est très douloureux il vous est pris
entre autres provisions en complément
avec show comique et vos valeurs et
cette dernière dassier n'y songe aux
mâles de convection et met en jeu qui
viendraient en attente
le pdg fondateur d'amazon jeff
bezos
avec l'année
que le corps sans vie
il montre à dos
cen'est pas eu lieu oui le liboux autres
avant dix
autres banques casse mon honneur c'est
ce que les autres disent universal alors
mais non les français
que vous devez lui mais ne rentre ou
développer 11e
à la race
parfois denses et a annoncé il a insisté
sur le fait qu'il faut créer uniquement
fondremand avant six mois et re fait
parallèlement
vous commencer il faut commencer va
venir quantification de force
eh oui premier français est motivé face
aux fins et quels éléments qui m'ont dit
cela est dit demerit votre marque et une
fois et l'enseigné il faut tout miser
sur elle
[Musique]
pour les faire connaître et par la suite
et si vous avez de la difficulté à
identifier vos capacités ou potentiels à
se
demander
quel complément recevez-vous
très calmement à propos de travail de
l'onu pour moi les gens demandent ils
ont
tout simplement
essayer de voir avec facilité et avec
voilà
quand c'est bidon de
déterminer ce qui vous rend excès
spécial
unis
selon william
hauteur
le pincement dans la rue
c'est étrange manière de scanner au
quotidien c'est à dire
vous le devez charges qu'elle ferait
une autre personne pourrait
rester authentique on a raison des
principes et valeurs qui vous avez
pensé lillois
orientez vos ambitions
remonter cinq cent dix ans en essayant
d'apporter des réponses à des questions
qu'est-ce qui vous incite à vous
dépasser
qu'apportez vous à votre chien
à l'organisation à votre métier à la
société et aux routiers et cette
motivation à la planète et à sortir dans
votre plainte
ce faisant
vous allez des mots sur une question
chevaux enjoignent se pose
est quand des investissements 4 euros à
l'entreprise et l'entraîneur va vous
aider à décrire notre mission
personnelle
[Musique]
quatrième cancer
a pêché doublement
après cinq ans soit
bien je suis même très bien cerné
comprenant
il faut la notion de fass demande
premier pas
les développeurs
habitués les conflits sur les
[Musique]
avec beaucoup d'intensité et montreux
mission personnelle
[Musique]
vérifie pour une pub pour pouvoir
déceler les éléments qui ne sont pas là
monial et rodrigue entités
cédées qu'on sorte à ce que votre
présence dans les dix
personnalités
prometteur
[Musique]
voilà c'est fait
j'ai
apprécié les 4e asus ou paiement de
l'île de beauté et de faire fonctionner
autrement
[Musique]
selon
sana
les
noms des prix différents
[Musique]
selah sue mais c'est la terminale
[Applaudissements]